bonjour thierry coville merci de
répondre à nos questions
l'ultraconservateur ebrahim raïssi élus
donc président d'après les premiers
résultats 62% des voix et un taux
d'abstention proche de 50% que traduit
se bat et quelle signification en terme
de participation
alors ce vote traduit le fait que
l'ingénierie comme dit comme ces
derniers environ lors l'organisation des
élections pour faire élire un
ultraconservateur qui a été menée par le
camp du guide ali khamenei a marché
l'objectif c'était de faire qui est un
taux de participation de plus fait
possible et ce qui devrait limiter les
candidats pour que préparer l'élection
de raïssi qui était le candidat préféré
des ultra conservateurs et lui dit
d'aller ramer lié à ça marche et le prix
le prix c'est quand même un taux
d'absence sur le taux de participation
reste élevée quand on compare à ce qu'on
connaît habituellement dans les autres
pays mais c'est un recul de - 20 points
2 par rapport à la dernière élection
présidentielle de 2007 qui montrent
qu'il ya une partie très importante
on va dire la classe moyenne éduquée qui
a voulu dit kadhi non calinon refuse ce
jeu électoral parce que vous avez
limiter le camp des candidats il ya
aucun candidat qui nous convient donc ça
la fout on va dire un succès pour le
camp des gitans des rangs mais quand
même un échec on va dire pour la
démocratie en iran ebrahim raïssi était
pressenti pour succéder à hassan rohani
donc qu'est ce qui va changer maintenant
il se présente comme le champion des
classes défavorisées et de la lutte
contre la corruption alors le paradoxe
de cette élection c'est que le problème
principal pour les iraniens c'est le la
crise économique grave que connaît le
pays or c'est pas dans les mains du
président c'est le sait crise économique
la situation va s'améliorer si les états
unis reviennent dans la corde 2015 et
s'ils annulent les sanctions et c'est ce
qui est en train de se négocier à vienne
on voit très bien aussi
on va dire la stratégie du pouvoir et du
guide qui consiste à vous dire quand
même un accord mais après l'élection de
récit s'il ya un accord et que les états
unis revient dans l'accord les sanctions
seront levés la situation économique va
s'améliorer et donc le président
nouvellement élu aura beau jeu de dire
regardez moi
arrive au pouvoir la situation
économique s'améliore du côté des
réformes je pense faut pas attendre
grand-chose sur l'intégration de l'iran
dans l'économie mondiale attirer
l'investissement étranger
par contre je pense que raïssi n'est pas
content des relations commerciales avec
le reste du monde et notamment avec
l'europe et il va peut-être si mener une
politique populiste éventuellement avec
des plus de subventions pour les plus
pauvres
fidèle à sa promesse lutter contre la
corruption mais je pense que ce sera
plutôt des effet d'annonce voilà et puis
alors sans doute s'il y aura plus
d'argent quand même investir dans les
infrastructures parce que c'est serré
dans ce domaine a eu beaucoup de retard
de prix depuis la dernière décennie
vous avez parlé de ce qui se passe à
l'international
avec notamment donc le nucléaire iranien
on sait que des négociations se
poursuivent du côté de vienne où se
situe le siège de l'eeie à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
d'ailleurs avec les rangs a prolongé
jusqu'au 24 juin un arrangement
technique pour permettre de poursuivre
les pourparlers dans de bonnes
conditions
passé ce 24 juin qu'est ce qui va se
passer exactement ce que c'est une date
importante parce que c'est ce que je
vous ai dit je pense
d'après ce qu'on sait techniquement
l'accord il est quasiment sur la table
mais il faut voir les moyens de
l'annoncer à la fois aux états unis en
iran qui elle est un environnement
politique
comment dire correct qui permettent de
dire à chaque pays regardez on a gagné
une victoire notamment en iran aux états
unis donc je me disais je pense quand
même que maintenant on peut se diriger
vers un accord à retour des etats-unis
dans l'accord avant le magasin autrement
bon je veux dire de nouveau pouvoir
céder dur mais ils sont pragmatiques
s'ils pensent qu'ils sont proches d'un
accord ils peuvent re négocier une
nouvelle à nouvel accord avec l'agent
sainte-thérèse énergie atomique pour se
mettre d'accord pour que les relations
soient maintenues jusqu'à un nouvel
accord
mais je pense que maintenant les
conditions sont réunies pour un accord
bon tout reste à savoir quel l
environnement que l'environnement
politique soit propice pour une telle
annonce on sert un depuis que les
etats-unis ont quitté l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2016 à vienne
le fameux jcp aux as
l'iran se désengage chaque jour un petit
peu et on sait que cette semaine il ya
eu un gros sommet à genève entre joe
biden le président américain et son
homologue vladimir poutine qui ont tous
les deux veulent affirmer leur volonté
de ne pas voir téhéran se doter de
l'armé nucléaire
oui m'enfin bon vous connaissez
l'histoire c'est bien que moi l'iran
avait signé l'accord en 2015
donc cet accord garantit c'est que le
problème nucléaire restera civile
jusqu'en 2025 qui relie la pagaille là
dedans c'est les américains c'est dans
la très passante en de l'accord alors
que l'iran le respecter
l'iran a réagi de la manière rationnelle
à cette situation et a commencé à dire à
partir de la mi-2010 9 nous on prend des
mesures pour détricoter d'accord mais si
les états unis ont bien d'accord on a dû
tout donc vous voulez on est toujours à
mon avis à cette situation là si les
états unis reviennent dans l'accord et
bien les rangs l'a dit un c'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de négocier à
vienne on essaie ce que je dis la
correction est sur la table
si les états unis annule toutes les
sanctions qu'ils ont pris en 2018 l'iran
automatiquement annulera toutes les
mesures qu'ils ont prises depuis la
mi-2009 et reviendra dans l'accord 2015
c'est ça qui est en négociations à
vienne donc ces déclarations comme quoi
il faudra jamais que l'iran atteignent
laboratory c'est quand même d'avoir les
etats-unis qui ont provoqué cette
situation
en sortant de l'accord en mai 2018
comment vont réagir selon vous les
grandes capitales mondiales à cette
élection d brahim raissi pas encore de
message de félicitations de la part des
diverses diplôme acier oui je veux pas
trop d des messages de félicitations à
part peut-être sauf de courtoisie de
politesse mais ont très clairement on a
le pouvoir iranien s'annonce ultra donc
il va rester anti-occidentale la
politique on va dire de la présence de
l'iran dans la région avec raïssi comme
président ça va pas changer
donc en gros c'est un renard à une
politique qui sera très liée au désir du
guide suprême ali khamenei
donc c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
l'occident d'un autre côté ça devient
plus
en iran et puis je pense qui s'annonce
aussi c'est que même avec les ultras à
la tête de l'iran ils sont pragmatiques
c'est pour ça qu'ils veulent un accord
avec les états unis parce que ça
permettrait de sortir de la crise
économique par contre c'est vrai et
c'est pour ça que le guide ali khamenei
veut un ultra comme président il veut
qu'il ya un accord avec les états unis
mais par contre il n'est pas question
qu'il y ait d'autres accords avec les
états unis sur la politique régionale de
l'iran ce point balistiques ont donc les
tensions avec les etats-unis
éventuellement avec l'occident vont
rester élevés avec raïssi président
merci thierry coville d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialiste de l'iran et chercheur
à l'iris institut des relations
internationales et stratégiques